Godley lovely to meet you lovely to meet
you too for viewers who haven't
encountered your music how would you
describe yourself I always get asked
this and I never really know what to say
because it's changed so much but I
usually say I make pop music but for
maybe people who don't really like pop
music music I think so yeah I mean I
think I would be being arrogant if I
said oh you know I am the only one who's
trying to say anything in pop music cuz
I think there's a lot of people saying
important things in pop music especially
now and in the last couple years but I
definitely think yeah I'm just I made
kind of quirky pop music and I do you
know I think there are a lot of people
who listen to my music who maybe love
you know your radio chart music and then
people who like never thought they'd
like pop music and listening to me so to
the mid term there will be those who
kind of see that you see the pink here
the kind of quite feminine that their
name yeah and might expect that your
music would be kind of bubblegum right
yeah and it's not it's not no I think
that's kind of what I wanted to do when
I chose the name and with the pink hair
and I think I kind of wanted to
challenge people's expectations of me a
little bit and look at you know what
with the name girly as well I kind of
wanted to say well why you know when I
say go e to people yeah they do expect
that kind of sweet you know cute kind of
music and and it's a lot of it's not a
lot of it's quite aggressive and
in-your-face and I just wanted to
challenge why do we assign gender also
things why do we say that something's
girly or masculine or this or that you
know when actually you can kind of be
anything and yeah I know the pink hair
it's funny like I I've had it for so
long now I kind of forget that I have
pink hair it feels like natural hair do
you think it's possible for for you to
separate your singing from you know that
your identity I mean people will still
look at your femininity in a sense as a
recording artist that I mean there's
only one Adele and there are lots of you
know young attractive girls out there
yeah
I think it's it's a really interesting
discussion because I I think it's more
about owning who who you are and seeing
as your identity rather than your
identity as a woman or as a man or as a
specific you know for me and yeah of
course you know I'm I'm in a world where
there's there's a lot and in the past
and still today there's a lot of over
sexualized images of women particularly
and where do you stand in the Photoshop
debate I don't want to be photoshopped I
I think one of the big things for me is
I've struggled with body image and you
know eat eating disorders and things
like that and I I think it's so
important to portray a real image of
myself so for me I think then of that of
those who those who do I mean take it
that some of the Kardashians you know
hyper sexualized individuals
photoshopped within an inch of their
life I mean honestly I think my main
opinion is that I think people should do
what they want to do my view on the
Kardashians and that kind of thing is I
think I think it can be damaging more so
less the hyper sexualized idea and I'll
talk more about that in a minute but I
think just the idea of having to look
this idea of perfect I think that is
really damaging because you know instead
of just saying who you are is perfect
and you know it's fine if someone has
you know an incredibly statuesque body
or if someone's really skinny or this or
that that's their body and you know I
think everyone's beautiful with their
own bodies but I guess the damaging
thing about the Kardashians is that you
know it's like there's really young
people on you seeing images of them and
thinking oh I need to look like that and
you know I guess it does make me feel
kind of sad sometimes you know when when
I see someone who's really young
thinking they have to like contour thier
face and look you know older or or that
idea of sexy but I definitely I think in
terms of sexual ization I think I think
for me
what I try to do is just do what I want
to do so if I if I want to wear less
clothes in the photoshoot that's my
decision to summit does feel almost like
there is there is a crisis in gender
identity these days people are are
struggling with it in a way in which
they have it in the past
what's your views to why we're here what
in this position I don't think it's a
crisis at all actually I think it's um I
think if anything it's a revelation I I
think it's people realizing and people
having more freedom to discover who they
are and find out their identities and
you know a lot of my friends and fans
and people I know identify as non-binary
so they don't want to be identified as
female or male I have a lot of friends
who have transitioned from you know male
to female or female to male and I think
it's amazing that they're there is more
of a discussion about it and there is
more of an acceptance you know in some
situations there still a long way to go
in terms of trans rights and you know
accepting people who don't want to be
who will want to be gender fluid but I I
definitely wouldn't ascribe it as a
crisis I think it's actually maybe
something maybe some people see it as a
crisis because they think you're
confused if you you know who you're not
sure how you want to be identified but I
think it's really great because to me I
I see it as no different to you thinking
like you know what do I want to do in
life what I want to do as a job well you
know it's like a part of your identity
that I think you should be able to
choose and develop that does seem to be
the word at least I'm a little bit of
tension I think even you've identified
it sometimes with the areas of feminism
and those campaigning for trans rights
not as someone who I'm sure would
identify as a feminist I mean I just
know you feel I there are people who are
feminists who are protest against trans
rights and I think that's disgusting
right well here I think that the women
who who say that trans women don't
aren't included in the back of women or
whatever they say I think that's just
ridiculous I think that if you identify
as a women you are involved in
discussion about women's rights and even
if you don't identify as women you're on
but you're involved in that discussion
because feminism for me I don't think it
should be this exclusive thing it should
be intersection that should be inclusive
of everyone because it's more about
equality than separating groups of
people you know how much power do you
think that women have in 21st century
Britain more power than they used to but
there's still a long way to go for sure
I think that the going back to it but
you know the internet and social media
because it has had such a massive
influence on the last like you know 5 10
years I think definitely gives women
more power in terms you know for example
I I go through a record label I work
with other people you know I work I do
work with a lot of men but I also have a
social media platform that's mine and
that I am in control of and that gives
me a lot more freedom and independence
to do what I want to do and say what I
want to say and I think the culture is
changing um I definitely think that for
example the me2 movement which happened
a lot in film and and TV I think needs
to happen for the music industry I mean
it's still I'm presuming an industry
that's not not necessary in terms of
artists but in terms of management and
those running the the record that was
still dominated by me oh completely yeah
it is I think that that still majorly
needs to change but is changing at the
same time and I think you know you first
start with people's attitudes and then
slowly it's like ripples and then it
becomes a wave and if you look at how
different and how much more independent
big you know female artists have these
days it has changed a lot in the last
you know 20 years or whatever I mean
people like you know the big stars like
Rihanna who you can see compared to when
she first came out and was quite
manufactured and was clearly sort of
being told what to do and
it's just kind of like well I'm gonna do
what I want to do and came out with this
album ante which was really different
and you know clearly driven by her I
think there's a just the attitudes are
changing there's a lot more people
saying yeah women should have more of a
choice and more power and when that
starts to change then slowly everything
starts to change
have you felt uncomfortable as you've
moved through this this particular
industry I at times I am
I've been lucky and I've have a great
team my managers are awesome and I
definitely there's other lyrics and
other songs I've talked to about you
know being treated like being talk talk
to play someone a song and they'll start
talking to me like about it and all you
should do this you should do that as if
I don't know how to write a song more as
if I don't know how to produce music
just cuz I'm a woman and you know I also
have a lot of friends for example who
women who make their own music
completely and then people will say oh
who wrote your song for you and it's
like me you know so there's there's
definitely still those kind of Prius
like assumptions I guess there's so much
of you so much of what you talk about it
seems to nudge towards that the
political sphere I mean I'm wondering
what you're thinking right now
um disappointed I think I think I mean
it's occupying your your generation as
much as I keep being told that it is
it's genuinely I think when I talk to a
lot of friends about it I think my
generation has kind of switched off of
mainstream politics because we're so
sick of it and I think it's just it is
hard when there's zero representation of
your age group on you know political
news channels and in political
discussions and when actually we're the
ones who are being probably most
affected by things like brexit but we're
not really getting a say in it and I
think it for me anyway I i definitely
watch whenever I turn on the news and
watch politics I kind of feel like God
everyone's just there's so much
arguing and squabbling and it you know
it is frustrating to be honest and I
think my generation is very politically
involved in a really different way to
previous generations I think are
involved in our own campaigns and our
own issues rather than necessarily
really involved in mainstream politics
we don't do enough people vote I mean
enough young people because it strikes
me that those perhaps a vicious circle
here young people feeling marginalized
by the political process well they don't
anymore and become an adjuster on going
I think in the last couple years since
brexit and then with the most recent
election there's become a lot more
awareness of young people voting and I
definitely notice a lot more that people
are encouraging each other to vote
people are posting all over their social
media and there's a vote coming up
saying vote you know have your voice
heard whereas before I am I think a lot
of people were like don't vote don't
bother you know and now I think there's
definitely an awareness that our vote is
more important than we used to consider
it and again I think social media is is
a big influence on that people posting
around and sharing and things going
around and you know that's the mean
that's the main source of news really
for for us instead of turning on the TV
you go on Twitter more you know so I
think the awareness of voting is is
better than used to be so just in terms
of where you go next as an artist as a
woman as an individual I mean where do
you see yourself going the next five
years I've no idea I I used to I used to
get really worried about it and for
planning a lot but I'm like I'll just
see where the wind blows so I mean I'm
gonna keep putting out music and keep
standing up for things I believe in and
I want to keep traveling and you know
hopefully I don't know what's going to
happen next year in terms of this
country but I'm definitely excited for
people like my sister's age as well to
kind of in a couple years to see how
that generation starts doing things and
shaking things up as well and if you had
to try and sum up in a few
the core of your message mm-hmm to your
fan base what would it be
oh my gosh probably standing up for what
you believe in and being yourself but
also standing up for other people and
other people's rights and mostly my
message is just don't do you don't care
about what other people think Kelly
thanks very much for joining us thank
you